We've done some simple code at this point, to load assets and resources in
memory. But as our code base gets more complex, we'll quickly find that we need
additional power and flexibility to help us get larger amounts of data into
memory. For example, what if you issue a load of the same file multiple times.
Well, each load will hit disk or at worst the web, and load that asset into
memory. This can become a large performance burden as each from disk fetch can
have performance costs. As an improvement, it would be great if once an asset
had been loaded, to know if it's in memory already, so that we can return the
in memory version, rather than going back to hitting the disk, or the web,
multiple times. This concept starts us down the path of an asset loading
manager, which we'll cover in this unit. Now in contrast to other languages
which handle File I/O as a synchronous or a blocking functionality, all File
I/O functions in JavaScript are by definition asynchronous. As you already saw
before, we specify a load function that is called later, once the image has
been loaded. This is a benefit to JavaScript, because we don't have to put
together all the logic of communicating between threads in order to load our
assets asynchronously. Giving HTML5 an edge in terms of features for gaming.